i'm an economist and i lean neoliberal i
lean toward open markets and free trade
and
letting the prices do their work i i
don't like the green new deal because
these people want to absolutely run our
economy on behalf of their
vision about how the future should look
and that that that terrifies me i think
taxes are
generally speaking too high i think
regulation
can go often does go over the top
uh and impedes uh uh impedes our
prosperity
i think the way forward has been shown
by capitalism
with a c capitalism not with a k
etc so you know that makes me somewhat
of a conservative
i write a lot about racial issues and
i'm cutting against the grain there
i think the country has lost its mind
with this diversity and inclusion stuff
i'm not a big fan of affirmative action
i think reparations would be an absolute
disaster for this country as well as for
african americans we could talk about it
but so so they call me a conservative
and i'm not fighting with them about it
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
professor of economics at brown
university
a distinguished fellow of the american
economics association
and a member of the u.s council on
foreign relations
glenn lowery welcome to the reuben
report
thanks dave good to be with you how'd i
do on the bio there you have
quite an extensive bio i've got the
whole thing here i left off like 10
things that probably could have been the
lead thing
i'm a member of the american
philosophical society i'm kind of proud
of that because those are the guys that
write and the girls that write the big
books
and i don't know why they included me in
their number i haven't written any big
books but
the american philosophical society all
right there you go so before we get to
anything else i want to ask you
about that shirt because you flashed me
something right before we started
straight out of quarantine are you a
free man in a free country right now
well i have contracted been treated for
and recovered from covet 19 knock on
wood thank god
uh so uh you know yeah i mean it's a
my wife bought this shirt for me it's
kind of a play on the old uh
uh hip hop rappers straight out of
compton
so i'm straight out of quarantine and
glad to be free at last real last well
actually let's
let's start there i wasn't planning on
doing too much kind of covert related
stuff to you
but what do you what do you make out of
what has happened
in the last year related to covet and
lockdowns and then i think some of that
will probably get us into some of the
social issues of the day which is what
you're
talking about a bit more church what is
that you're inviting me into there dave
you can say the wrong thing and get
canceled
i mean a number of things don't worry no
nobody's been canceled because of me
yeah yeah i'm a social scientist so the
first thing i think about is what are
the kinds of studies that people are
going to do for years
assessing what happened here
and there are many dimensions to it
there's the public health dimension to
it there was a pandemic a pathogen it
spread in the population people died
uh how effective were the various
responses to that
shutdowns masking and stuff like that
but i think there are also
political things here for example
donald trump was hated by a lot of
people they hung this around his neck
now maybe he didn't handle it as well
i don't i think i'll retract it maybe he
didn't handle it as well as he could
have handled it
okay on the other hand here was an
opportunity to think donald trump and i
think a lot of people seized on it so
one of the interesting political
questions to me is how did the partisan
character of american politics and the
role the media plays in that
affect the way that this thing was
reported but there are many many
dimensions to it so the social pressure
to conform you know have you been
vaccinated and i'm for getting
vaccinated i've been vaccinated myself
i'm not you know i'm not against being
vaccinated
tucker carlson whom i follow from time
to time is on the tear about the masking
stuff and there is a real question there
i mean
the government is going to tell me what
i have to put on my face
that works maybe in an absolute
emergency situation but when that
becomes a way of life
you have to start asking the question
about individual freedom and so on
so there's just many different pieces to
it that i expect
will be examined by serious people for
years to come
yeah was there anything that shocked you
just about the general way not that not
the media but just the way
people sort of became so hyper-partisan
about a virus meaning that the mask has
become sort of i'm a democrat
the non-mask is i'm a republican
something like that
sort of loosely speaking well there's
that's one aspect of it i mean
and you know some people were just
absolutely terrified i mean they
wouldn't come out of their houses they
had
their groceries they would wipe down
everything with a cloth
and i thought that was over the top i
thought that was excessive but then
how do we handle risk everybody is going
to react to it differently
so what i was saying to my friends was
you know if you told me
there was a one in a thousand chance
that i would die if i stepped from my
front door
i might stay inside for a week maybe two
weeks
after that i take my chances you know
what i mean so
you know don't impose your risk
preference on me that was kind of my
you know and i'm like it takes two to
tango so if i want to have a dinner
party and the people don't want to show
up what can i do
uh but i i did feel that there was a lot
of over-the-top
uh kind of overreaction to school
staying close to what now i'm not an
expert on the data about school closings
but my colleague emily oster
is at brown university's economics
department look her up
she had a piece of the new yorker about
this she is an expert she's a liberal
she's a liberal
and they just tried to tear her apart
because she said
school should open up because she said
the data don't justify keeping the kids
away from the classroom you're doing
more harm than you're doing good
the cure is worse than the disease where
did i hear that before
she said it she said it and they tried
to take her head off
so you know it was really really a
very interesting and very pathological
situation from the way in which we made
decisions as a society
i think politics fear panic
uh groupthink you know these were these
were all at play
what do you consider yourself
politically
do you specifically say i'm this i'm
that on the other thing because when i'm
listening to you i sense a little bit of
everything which by the way
that's probably how most people really
are we just get hung up on the lake okay
so i'm registered independent
uh i don't tell people how i vote what i
was telling them during last year's
presidential election is
of course i voted for biden what else
would you expect me to say and then i'd
laugh and i'd say
i can't say anything else you you still
don't know who i voted for if i tell you
i voted for biden because if i voted for
the other guy
i'd never tell you i voted for it but
i'm a conservative
i think i just have to admit that now
you know on a number of different
dimensions
i'm an economist and i lean neoliberal i
lean toward open markets and free trade
and
letting the prices do their work i i
don't like the green new deal because
these people want to absolutely run our
economy on behalf of their
vision about how the future should look
and that that that terrifies me i think
taxes are
generally speaking too high i think
regulation
can go often does go over the top
uh and impedes uh uh impedes our
prosperity
i think the way forward has been shown
by capitalism
with a c capitalism not with a k
et cetera so you know that makes me
somewhat of a conservative i write a lot
about racial issues
and i'm cutting against the grain there
i think the country has lost its mind
with this diversity and inclusion stuff
i'm not a big fan of affirmative action
i think reparations would be an absolute
disaster for this country as well as for
african americans we could talk about it
but so so they call me a conservative
and i'm not fighting with them about it
yeah i i hear you and i think what you
just said right there sums up
what most of my audience probably is at
some level whether you know some are
maybe a little more libertarian or a
little more
traditionally conservative or whatever
it is but you you just gave me a great
uh sort of lead on everything else i
want to talk about because
uh one of the things that i want to talk
about is we hear this phrase systemic
racism all the time and i've heard you
talk about this i've read some of your
stuff on this
in some ways we're just not all talking
about
the same thing when we say the phrase
systemic racism so can you lay out
maybe what you believe it to mean versus
what you think some other people think
it means okay in the simplest terms
here's what i think people are saying
they're saying back in the old days of
the civil rights movement civil rights
act of 1964 martin luther king and all
of that
the issue was racist treatment unequal
treatment of people discrimination and
housing
and jobs and credit markets and so on
blacks weren't treated the same they
were discriminated against
and the goal was equal treatment which
is why king is there saying uh i have a
dream that my kids will be judged by the
content of their character he doesn't
want him discriminated against he
doesn't want him kept from voting
because they're black
he doesn't want him kept from shopping
because they're black he wants them to
be treated like anybody else that's the
old school
thing systemic racism is declaring there
to be a new day
because guess what we pretty much have
solved the discrimination problem
not completely but just about as
completely as you could solve it in a
free society
every state has an equal employment
opportunity commission there's a ton of
lawsuits that you can bring against your
employer if you think you're not being
treated fairly
god help a retailer if he actually does
discriminate and charge a different
price to a black customer
right right because so which we would
all be against
just to get yeah against that that bit
has been solved
yeah but the disparities are still there
okay blacks are overrepresented amongst
the incarcerated
underrepresented amongst the students at
a fancy college
uh have lower wealth holdings etc etc so
the disparities are there
but the account of the disparities that
black person was discriminated against
is no longer very uh effective as an
explanation
so people are calling on larger forces
not
personal one-on-one historical forces
i mean here's an example new orleans
floods
black people on average live at lower uh
level sea level
so they get flooded worse they get
flooded worse because they're poor
they get flooded worse maybe because in
the history of new orleans i don't know
anything about it specifically but this
is just a hypothetical
they were discriminated against and the
high ground housing wasn't as easily
those neighborhoods weren't the re real
estate agents didn't show them whatever
whatever
they got worse jobs you know etc so
they're on the low line so then the
flood comes and they discriminate
now some of us would think you know
that's an unfortunate act of nature and
then you know
just like if a pandemic comes and you
got more uh co-morbidities and
pre-existing conditions you're going to
get a harder hit but it's not an act of
racism
a person might say but the systemic
racism people want to say oh no no no
it is an act of racism you see that
disparity
the history of race in america is what
has made that disparity happen
then they have this story in this case
uh the blacks are in the low-lying
neighborhoods in
new orleans because of discrimination in
the past and racism
and so that's their story mass
incarceration is racist
why because well the drug laws are what
they are and they wouldn't be what they
are if the people who were being locked
up were
mostly white people or not they have
their accounts they're not enough blacks
at caltech
why because of systemic racism in the
education system and so on
so it's an effort to explain disparities
in the absence of individual racist
discriminatory acts that's how i
understand it if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell